Oh, hey. What's up? Hold on one sec. >> Dude, Destiny's
literally watched this guy's videos where he like lies to get
hired at the Daily Wire. I'm surprised he doesn't I don't know
if Alex Novel just has like a face that disappears. Oh, never
mind. That's why Destiny can't tell who he is. [laughter]
All right, let's check out this Alex Neville video. You guys
remember Alex Neville did [music] a hit piece. Would you say
that >> he did a documentary on Johnny Somali and all the
people who went to Korea to cover him and a big part of that
documentary was on legal mindset. Okay. He had a bunch of stuff
for legal mindset. He kind of published some allegations without
a lot of proof. Okay. He he published some allegations that were
like he basically was like, "Okay, these are these are allegations.
They should be on the record somewhere." Legal Mindset released
a really bad piece like defending against it and then everything's
been silent since. So, I don't know what Alex Novel's been up
to. I know he's watched stuff on this channel before. I'm interested
to see. Apparently, he tricked Essie into debating Hassan Piker's
strongest soldier. Is this What is this going to be? This isn't
related to Kathy, is it? Cuz Kathy is definitely Hassan Piker's
strongest soldier, but I don't know if that's what Alex Neville
thinks.
Or Ogre Boy or Ogre Boy. It's It's kind of up in the air. I don't
know which.
so he he did a piece on Destiny. No spoilers. Do not spoil the
video. Okay, I'm pointing out that Alex Neville in the past has
stretched things or said things that are unprovable. I think
he goes he's kind of more of a narratively driven guy and I've
seen that before. So, we'll we'll watch and we'll see, you know,
what's being said. We'll see what we can track. Maybe we can
support some of his points. Maybe he won't know stuff. I don't
know. Or maybe we could just straight up say, "No, this is bull."
Actually, I'm not sure. I'm excited to see. Let's check it out.
wield your audience more like a shield than like a sword. >> I
mean, I try to in that sense, but I'll wield them like a sword
as well for things that I believe in. >> Streamer Destiny
is saying that it's justifiable to attack and kill me in real
life. >> Hassan was terrified of fear, the terror in Hassan's
eyes.
>> Culture war.
Culture war never changes.
In the year 2025,
every community >> Hey, it's he does his own little aesthetic
thing. Okay, it's just a it's just an aesthetic flare. Don't
>> Don't worry about it. You don't like it. >> He's
at war with each other. >> When the war comes to me, I
have no choice but
>> he believes you are unhinged. Beware >> to defend
myself.
>> I'm being invaded by a bunch of commies.
Let's go to war >> in the online culture war. I am the
strongest soldier. >> Alex novel is the strongest Hanabi
head. This is the strongest Hanabi soldier. >> A warrior.
>> I see. He tricked him into debating himself. I see.
>> Time to stop judgment day from
>> But it's getting closer every day.
Behind the constant fighting, there's one entity pulling all
the strings, stoking the flames,
the flames of war.
One terrible force, death set on destroying everything and everyone
that dares to criticize it. That one force can only be reckoned
with if you have two unbeatable weapons.
It's debate time. Content terminator destiny. Okay.
He's not a content cop. He's the content terminator. All right.
All right. I'll lean in.
>> All right. Here we go. Debating someone like Destiny
isn't easy. >> How many of you? >> Not half as many
as you, sir. >> Your mic's not on. >> Destiny is
basically [laughter] the liberal version of Ben Shapiro. So when
he does actually debate people, it's usually meant to farm clips
for his multiple social media channels. And this is the legend
Destiny over here, everybody. You get a chance to debate him
one-on-one. So if anybody else wants to come up and debate and
you're choosing to do this now after Charlie Kirk was doing it
for 16 years or however many years, and that's why you're here
trying to imitate the exact same thing. >> I would never
I would never be so low that I would imitate such a loser like
Charlie Kirk. Number one. Okay. Number two. Okay. I've been doing
these events >> Charlie Kirk had the balls to talk against
Israel. So, if I ever wanted to face Destiny in an epic debate
of facts and logic, I had to get him in a private call where
he couldn't showboat to his >> I even like mean set him
up. I was like, "Watch this audience." >> How are you lying
about this? >> Shut up, Destiny. >> Oh, wait. Did
he like set up a total like a debate with a third party? Is that
what he did? >> Holy [__] You're so You're
so shameless, dude.
>> HAVE HAD ENOUGH WITH YOUR STUPID DOG. >> WHO IS
THE VIDEO? Who is Hey, who is the >> I can't do it. >> Who
is the guy? Who [laughter] is the guy on the
>> I forgot that XQC did that. He's That's probably about
the best, you know, the best way to deal with this guy. Just
scream at him repeatedly and then walk >> Top middle. Who
is the run? Who is that video of? Who is that? >> Undefeated
XQC is okay.
>> Quick, anybody? Can anybody remember what he debated
Ethan Klein on? Or all is all you remember that he did the worm
once with Ethan Klein? He said, "All you guys are ever going
to remember about this is the worm." I guarantee it's the first
thing everybody thinks about when they know they could probably
go through their memory after that after thinking about the worm
and then they could come up with like the topics and maybe some
of the points, but for everybody the thing they really understand
about that is the worm. Okay, that's what they that's what they
remember. Did he walk >> But Destiny doesn't just get on
a private call with anyone. So, unless I wanted to pretend to
be a teenage girl, the next best thing was to go through his
right-hand man, Dan Saltman. Could you push Destiny a little
bit to talk to >> I'll tell him that the interview with
you went okay. Uh I I mean, >> wait, this guy really tricked
Dan to get a one-on-one with Destiny. Dude, I always watch I
watch this guy's stuff and I'm like, dude, he's going to like
burn all of his credibility, right? Eventually, people will know
who he is. I He just keeps getting people. He's not really worried
about people backstabbing him because he his community is [__]
insane. Like I I I don't know if you have you ever gone through
[__] with a community coming after you before. If
you know that level of insanity, you know that like of the communities
that are like most known for being insane, everyone says like
DG is the worst. I don't think it's the case, but like I don't
think Destiny is particularly worried about people backstabbing
him because, you know, nobody wants that heat,
[laughter] >> dude. Uh, actually, yeah, they'll just like
dox and and harass anybody. They'll they'll go after everybody
all the time. They'll lie about them in their replies all the
time. And nobody wants that heat. Yeah. I don't know if it's
the worst, but hey, nobody wants that heat. Good one. Good one.
[laughter] >> Yeah. Uh, anyways, but >> that's really
funny that Alex added this that he got this footage cuz it's
it's just very
obvious. It's very funny to me
that everybody just knows. It's like, yeah, you you'll like your
life on the internet will be hell if you cross this community.
Just know that. >> I I'll what I'll do is I'll um I'll
uh I'll message Destiny. I'm just saying I did an interview uh
with you about Hassan.
Um he's a guy. He mentioned he reached out to you and and say
that the >> Did he tell you that I uh reached out to him?
Did did like did you guys know that I like >> we uh we
we haven't talked uh very much cuz he's just going through some
crazy [__] right now. >> So finally everything
was set up for me to talk to Destiny. But first he had to >> some
crazy.
He's just going through some crazy [__] right now.
We we haven't talked very much cuz he's just going through some
crazy [__] right now. Uh I'm not going to risk getting
you know nabbed with the Okay. I've harassed so many people who've
called me a on the internet and if I get if he goes down and
I'm friends with him and I'm partnered with him on stuff. I can't
get past those optics. Okay, that's what Dan is saying right
here. As soon as he thinks that's not a worry, Dan will be back.
He's got no issues, right? But he's not Listen, if Destiny's
going to catch a charge for
Dan knows that he doesn't want to be on the internet anymore
if that happens when he's around. He's going to he's going to
peace out. All right. >> So, finally, >> publicly
publicly >> everything was set up for me to talk to Destiny.
But first, he had to reschedu on me five different times and
then make a cringe mama joke to assert dominance before he could
join the call.
>> Oh, hey. What's up? Hold on one sec. >> Dude,
Destiny's literally watched this guy's videos where he like lies
to get hired at the Daily Wire. I'm surprised he doesn't I don't
know if Alex Novel just has like a face that disappears. people
like watch his videos and then they forget who he is. It's just
like something about his face. It just like melts out of your
brain
cuz I swear most people have watched that video, right? You guys
know what I'm talking about where he he faked like he I think
he ran through some interviews with the Daily Wire and kind of like
faked his way into it into like an internship with them.
Yeah. And people just forget him. >> There he is.
>> Okay, I'm here. I'm real. How's it >> It's going
good. I appreciate you doing this. I'll jump right in. I won't
waste your time. >> Destiny has been a controversial figure
on the internet for a long time now. But recently, it feels like
things are starting to reach their peak. Not only for Destiny,
but for the long-term hate campaign he's been running against
three-time winner of antagonist of the year, Hassan [__]
>> And the Destiny Award for antagonist of the year is
Hassan [__] >> Wow.
Good job, Hassan. Fighting hard for that rank one spot. Destiny's
community where he is calling for my death. At what point do
we stop? At what point do people in his orbit say, "Hey man,
I think you've gone too far." >> Since both of their permanent
bands on the live streaming platform Twitch, Destiny along with
his podcast co-host, >> they did Pisco dirty here. Wait,
why did they do I mean, if you know who Pisco is, it's it's fine.
probably
>> Dan Saltman have intensified their campaign to deplatform
or cancel Hassan [__] by any means necessary. >> Hassan
lost millions of dollars because of me. This cost Hassan
millions of dollars a year guaranteed. >> Dude, if I swear
like if people have archives of my streams with Dan's appearances,
dude, Dan Dan puts so many insane comments on the record. I don't
have archives of the stuff, but if he puts so many insane comments
on the record, if people have archives of this stuff and it starts
coming out in videos, I think it'd be like actually kind of rough
for him to operate um with like seriousness on the internet.
Like just all of the flip-flops, all of the being like, "Yeah,
we should just lie about people." All of those things. It's going
to be so rough.
Tell me how if I am I wrong or am I right? Cuz he right. >> Yeah.
There you go. There. Daddy is saying it's right for you. All
right, chat. Uh that's it. Again, there's nothing that the dynamic
here, by the way, of Destiny just being like, "Yeah, sure. Whatever
you said, buddy." And Dan is like fighting with chatters who
are like talking to him about nothing burgers. Destiny just said
that it totally wasn't a nothing burger, guys. So, stop saying
it was a nothing burger. This was not a nothing burger. Okay?
Stop saying that. Your your spiritual father just said it wasn't
a nothing burger. So, you have to stop saying it, too. Son can
do about it except take it like my [__] that he is.
You can't destroy a leftist as a centrist or a liberal. You can
only destroy them if you're a slightly slightly different more
extreme leftist. Then you create this division, you know, Hassan
and Dan Clancy, you know, being the dude that they can't destroy
and they're saying you can't destroy him to me. And it's like,
I know, but this person can. And it's like slightly different
leftist. Sorry, a little rambling there, but I just wanted to
drive the point home to you that um these people's success is
not based around their politics. And I know that sounds stupid.
It's based around the culture and the identity and um the
the the communities that they foster and develop in my community.
>> Oh yeah, Dan is a leftist. Dan is definitely a leftist
guys 100%. >> Will hit us on because we have severe epistemic
differences. Like our approach to how we do, you know, research
or truth or with other political opinions is quite different.
>> Talk to me about how you gather information versus how
>> Oh, never mind. That's why Destiny can't tell who he
is. [laughter]
Dude, why why don't you just let somebody know that they're they've
got no lights on. This guy's sitting here in the shadows. >> A
challenger approaches,
>> Talk to me about how
>> a challenger approaches, guys. Okay, you just unlocked
a new Smash character. >> How do you gather information
versus how he does?
>> Um, I feel like when I go to Hassan's stream, there's
a lot of people now where you basically just kind of go for like
marching orders. Like, what do progressives think right now?
What do tankies think right now? What do whatever. I mean, I
feel like that's the majority of media today. Um, but I I mean,
there's like pros and cons to it, but for better or for worse,
I don't really cleanly map on to any political ideology. So,
I'm kind of free of the pressure of having to agree with one
>> Trump in terms of his policies was not really that radical.
>> Not actually at all. He's actually agree. In terms of
policy, he wasn't he wasn't really that much different than than
even his even his Democrat predecessors. your your community's
been at war with Hassan's community, especially when it comes
to like >> guys, in his defense, in his defense, I believe
he was Lauren Southern at this point in time. Okay, in his defense,
I believe he was trying to court a at this exact moment in time.
In his defense,
I believe he was he was trying to [__] like some
blonde area at the time. Okay, so he was going to say anything
he wanted to or needed to. Okay, he was going to say anything.
>> Uh, I heard he's doing that now. I heard he's Yeah.
Well, you know, Lauren Southern was kind of done with Destiny
entirely and then she realized that the only way to guarantee
that that her son also becomes a is probably to get back together
with Destiny.
So, you know, in in terms of strategy, I can't really fault her.
>> Yeah. Kind of. >> What is your role in that in
terms of like
are you okay with that? Would you rather them not be at war?
Or is it better for the overall
continuing of the thing that you're building to have a community
that is galvanized in this
>> I mean, it really depends on what you mean by at war.
Like, I think it's good for us to, you know, further our beliefs
and ideas online. I think it's good to argue about things, especially
when we think somebody else is being untruthful. I'm a tit fortat
guy. If you want to roll in the mud, I'll gladly roll in the
mud with you. Um, I have a lot of experience doing it. This guy
just loves saying tit for tat. I You could probably pinpoint
exactly when this was based on him saying tit for tat. He went
like two weeks saying tip for tat to everything. Like literally
his definitional thing of like I never turn the other cheek.
I am a child. I will respond to everything. That that thing.
Okay. Tiff for tat. Tiff for tat. Tiff for tat. It's just a way
of saying yes, I am a child. I have no self-control. If you talk
about me, I'll I'll try to kill you. That's his that's his way
of saying that. >> A big history doing it and I have no
problem doing it. Destiny and Dan Saltman have waged a full-scale
information war, wielding their communities and resources to
spread their anti-Hassan message across the >> Is Hassan
going to create some people that are going to be terrorists or
or you know, I don't know how you would do it or I think there's
probably a very good chance that there will be some shootings
that get attributed to, you know, Hassan watchers. I think we
already have some.
Um, personally,
>> personally, oh, he he added the personally to say, I'm
clearly lying about this, but I personally believe this like
in my madeup world, I personally believe that there are some
shooters responsible, you know, Hassan's responsible for some
shooters. I can't prove it, but I personally believe it. But
um >> which was >> you know >> I would say
uh the
>> embassy shooting >> Rodri Rodriguez guy who did
the um the two shootings uh of the Israeli um staffer. I've shared
the information I have with that um with the relevant people.
So >> are you you know working alongside Dan a lot with
this stuff or what's your kind of perspective on the feeding
the trolls of it all? Um, Dan typically does his own thing. Uh,
for feeding the trolls, it really just depends. Like, you don't
want to get into the personal stuff too much cuz if you do, then
all the fights become personal. What a loser. God, he's such
a Neanderthal. He's such a slime piece of [__] He's
like skitso or not skitso. He's like a psychopath. >> Hassan
is the most uh deviant person I
>> That's [__] Hold on. Let me do my say
>> Desi is sitting here with logs on the internet about
how he wants to eat out of some girl's vagina. Okay. Logs here
about sharing butt plugs with a minor, right? And and Dan sitting
across from him fully aware of these logs existing and says Hassan's
the most deviant person I know. Like even Destiny's like, "Dude,
what are you talking? Hold on a second. What the [__]
are you saying, Dan? The [__] are you talking about,
bro?" Tarted whatever the you were about to say. That would completely
undermine exactly what I was saying. >> Destiny in this
way reminds me a lot of another guy who I spoke to once on this
>> Did OJ do it?
>> You know, >> Alan Destitz. Okay. >> Um,
maybe not once asked me that question and he was prime minister
and I said, "Does have nuclear weapons?" And he said, "Allan,
you know, I can't tell you that lawyers have confidences and
we can't we can't disclose those confidences just as prime ministers
of Israel have confidences." Destiny and Durowitz have a lot
in common. And it's not just their >> They're basically
the same guy. Yeah, I >> activities for young girls or
the state of Israel. They've both made careers out of framing
criticism as persecution while also thriving on confrontations
for their personal brand. I like I like that he didn't so he
actually had like real points to make and he didn't include those.
He just wanted like this graphic out there, right? He just he
wanted this up here. He has real things he's going to say after
>> as persecution while also thriving on confrontations
for their personal >> They're engaging. >> Yeah,
I'm I'm the victim for the things people say about me, but I
engage in like the most toxic way. Like in the most like costic
toxic way, right? Like I I engage I, you know, attack people
but I'm also the victim of people ever doing that to me. I'm
I'm a huge victim. Okay? When you treat me like I treat other
people, I'm the victim >> in bigotry. Look, I fought against
apartheid. I was part of the legal team for Nelson Mandela. I
know what apartheid is. How dare you quote Israel in a parttheid
state? >> Has Israel been committing a genocide? >> I
wouldn't say so, but >> Not yet. >> Not yet. >> Not
yet. Really? >> Yep. Really? Yep. Also like Dersuit, Destiny's
love of public confrontations and unwillingness to back down
from a fight would find him entrenched in a legal battle related
to allegations of streamer. Destiny may be legally trapped as
we look at this new scandal and we're turning to what may be
criminal charges. >> A few days ago, a Reddit post showed
that the girl Destiny shared Pixie's nudes with was seemingly
confirmed to be 17 years old due to her getting doxed. There
is almost a 0% chance that she was not 17 during that time. These
allegations, however serious, don't seem to actually phase Destiny's
controversy adult brain. >> Talk to me about like that
the day that like everything kind of blew up on Twitter. >> At least
he blurred it. Well, I think Willie went back and blurred his
video at this point. But I do find it very funny that Willie
doesn't understand why he was correct in any of that. I find
that very very very funny.
>> And and how you felt in your reaction to
everything which everything >> like all when everyone started
calling you a pet
>> at this point I'm basically I'm used to everything so
it is what it is I know if I just keep streaming and I do my
thing generally everything goes away after a week or two yeah
>> even more so than Destiny Dan Saltman has spent an insane
amount of time money >> oh is this guy going after Dan
oh boy and whatever other resources or connections he has to
try to destroy Hassan [__] And he says he's doing
it all because he's trying to stop
>> I already have my my money, right? I I don't have to
stream. I don't have to go and uh do anything on that front.
Like, I'm here and I can be as resourceful and impactful as I
want to be to try and make the world uh a better place through
hopefully uh just neoliberal
uh type of
um pressure and show the world reality of what it is. All right,
first off, this website, just to be clear, is not owned or operated
by Twitch. And this site is uh well, you know, you don't have
to read all that, but it's there. >> What's a gripe site?
>> Don't worry about it. >> This is uh Destiny's
podcast co-host, Orbiter, [laughter] who spends every wagon moment
actively trying to get me deplatform. I realize that I don't
have nearly the resources of what the, you know, the EDL or anyone
else has. The hatred.tv site is just another kind of piece in
that puzzle. The creation of these sites allows
their impact to reach a lot more people in a lot more uh
understandable way. All of a sudden it's not like a you know
an anti-semitism issue. Now it's just a like why why does Twitch
as a company push Hassan so >> oh this is a fantastic point
actually um when Willie Mack decided to air against Cher's you
know protests
sections of a non-consentually recorded tape right when he decided
to throw that in a video were DJers upset about that
no
not at all and now apparently putting like private information
in a video worst thing in the world. Worst thing Willy ever done,
guys. What a horrible person. What a horrible person. Now,
there are some of us who were able to call it out both times.
Actually, pie and protect him so much. >> Dan Saltman's
aggressive Zionism along with his regressive beliefs about free
speech on the internet have made him a powerful and outspoken
ally for destiny in the war against Hassan Biker. When I go through
hatred.tv, TV, right? I
>> that I look at like the each glowing dot in the field
represents a 100 anti-semitic messages in Had's chat and I click
on one and uh a lot of the stuff is like all Zionist pigs. uh
Israel already killed all of its own citizens that uh you know
uh
>> trying to read one for example
>> is is people saying all Zionists in Hassan's chat in
your mind a dog whistle for you know
>> um yes for the most part yeah um
I I I would almost absolutely usually
say that to be the case. I don't I think it's going to be incredibly
rare that it wouldn't be the case. People like to call me like
a ultra ultra Zionist genocidal maniac. And in my mind, uh I
think the Oh, boy. What is he trying to do? What is he doing
with the music? I don't like where the music's going. What is
this? What is this music?
I rec I recognize some some crazy about to happen. Okay. >> Zionist
genocidal maniac. And uh in my mind uh I think the should have
gotten uh half of Germany. I think that would have been the the
fair thing to have in that situation. So it's just [laughter]
you know but these people for their entire life have been told
that are evil um and that they want to destroy you and if you
kill one of them you're going to you're going to um you know
I don't know all the religious terms but it's crazy. And to in
to com combat that level of indoctrination
there has to be a massive influx of um resources into that area.
there needs to be a McDonald's on every corner and everyone there
needs to be driving a Ferrari. And it and I know it sounds stupid,
but it's only at that point that these people are are uh that
the residents of of of Gaza and the West Bank are going to be
like maybe, you know, let's focus on something besides cuz life
right now is pretty awesome.
>> When Dan Salman isn't podcasting with a fest or obsessing
over Hassan [__] he's running his company redact.dev,
dev an app that's supposed to help you delete your messages that's
designed about as well as his >> don't do the don't do
the redact saves all your stuff thing. Please don't please don't
please don'tesites.
>> So redact as a company came to be um a few years ago.
Redact has been based around the idea of letting you manage data
that you yourself have created. >> He went off today still
saying everyone else doxed rose. He had no part and spams your
community did for for days now. You become the boogeyman.
Yeah. Um I don't know what to like what can you even do about
that. Simpo. Nobody like there's
unfortunately there's like not really a way to break through
that for me. I would need I need like other people to kind of
give a [__] about it, right?
Um you can't just do content on it every day. And like when when
I point out the obvious lies, the obvious like
it doesn't affect anybody who's like left watching him or really
like obviously everybody in my community can see how he is like
that he's blatantly lying. There's no way to get through like
the to break through to anyone else. Uh we're kind of like force
fielded off from the rest of the internet right now, right? It's
uh it's like a weird thing. I can talk about it later at some
point. Um, but when you have like a lot of negative engagement
from communities that like hate you, it sort of
there there's there's problems with it, but we talk about it
after. >> If you ever feel like pushing it, let me know.
And um, you know, we have an affiliate program that I can can
get you in. But don't let the cluttered interface or the fact
that if you use his app it will disable your Discord account
be reasons that you never use a piece of technology designed
by Dan Saltman because he also created Tiny Chat. One of the
first >> Oh no, don't don't. He's going to talk about the
kids that got groomed on Tiny Chat. Oh no. >> Tools that
would use to video chat with teenage girls on the internet. I
don't know if you know this about me, but you know, a long time
ago, uh, I created the first like Twitch type website that there
was. We were bigger than Skype at one point. Uh, it was called
Tiny Chat. >> It's called Tiny Chat, and it's the latest
craze on the internet. Users need a Facebook, MySpace, or Twitter
account to access the site. And once they do, they are instantly
connected to millions of people by webcam.
>> Look what he's doing. Some of the chats are fun just
like Tiny Chat advertises, but others show people and in many
instances minors. We even found teenagers
themselves [laughter] to other >> He wants everyone to
>> see that >> with the budget cuts everywhere. >> I
police departments nowhere is going to have any sort of resources.
>> Oh, Dan tried to get Alex an affiliate sponsorship and
I didn't even >> I don't I don't hear the shilling
>> Go after something like that. So all all those things
said like um you know we ran that company very successfully.
We built it to um you know a huge amount of users. So I do feel
uh you know very knowledgeable. Uh >> you feel responsible
somewhat for like creating a monster in that way. >> Uh
no I I don't I don't feel responsible. There was we just you
know did group video chat and then you know people took it to
a level that was way more uh frisky afterwards. You had chat
roulette that came afterwards and that kind of gave everything
a really bad name. Beyond all of the shoddy tech and targeted
websites, Dan Saltman's biggest weapon is his ability to constantly
add his own ved perspective to the >> Why I do this is,
I think, because I I can. After October 7th, I was in a very
um I I felt strange. I thought, can I do something to stop this?
And and I I felt like um I could I felt like, you know, the success
that I've done with my businesses that I should be able to use
that to um find out this isn't about October 7th. It's not about
anti-semitism. It's like a petty power kick that is just been
playing itself out for a while. The the narrative, the reasoning
has changed a multitude of times. It's never stayed consistent
at all. It's just weird. It's weird to do all the different virtue
signals. He cares as much about anti-semitism as he cared about
his daughter when he was trying to get forthought removed, right?
Just like petty grievance. That's all it was. It's all it is.
It's all it ever is. It's whatever. >> What pressure points
I can push to make a positive change. I wish I did this thing.
I wish I spent more time with my kids. It's always all these
things I wish that I did. And I realized at the point like, you
know, this is going to be one of those things I think that I'm
going to regret later on in life is that like I had the opportunity
to make an impact and hopefully counter this narrative that like
old are evil. The ability to counter that um was
>> Dan Saltman's unwillingness to get a hobby or go spend
some time with his kids would be astonishing to most people,
but that's the way things go during the culture war. Veteran
debate lords like Destiny can't spend time with their kids when
there's a war going on, even if his own son falls victim to the
same online extremism that Destiny claims to fight against. >> You've
said that you are an You said that you
>> Dude, why did Drew Pavl do this? It's so
>> Endorse Adolf. >> Drew Pav is such a weirdo, dude.
Um and and and look these are these are pretty morally horrible
views in my view. The >> book I'm reading right now ironically
is mine come I'm trying to understand psychology
of >> I do want to ask you about like how your son's been
radicalized because I've seen a lot of his posts and interviews
about you know his beliefs on on you know and >> It's kind
of annoying cuz I said a lot of crazy stuff when I was a kid.
I mean I imagine right now he's going through his whole thing.
There's a lot of people online that are very motivated and >> Was
Destiny saying I feel like Destiny was pretty young when he first
started posting on the internet? I don't remember all of the,
you know, the Holocaust was fake rhetoric from Destiny. I don't
remember that part, but maybe. Is Destiny saying that he was
a when he was a kid and he grew out of it? There's a phase. It's
kind of like goth, but now it's a phase in trying to have him,
you know, turn out one way or another. Hassan and everybody else
likes to talk about him, but I mean like I chat with him. He's
14. if he still believes this when he's, you know, 16, probably
gonna be pretty worried. But people go through phases and I'm
not going to sit here and try to audit 14-year-old's beliefs
to make sure that they're perfectly in alignment with my, you
know, democratic liberal beliefs. I mean, people grow. As long
as he doesn't do anything that gets them kicked out of school,
then it'll be okay. Hopefully. >> Destiny claims that his
community is immune from extremists due to his innate ability
to tell which people are making racist jokes and which people
are actually racist. >> I don't know how to explain it.
It's like a I want to just call it a vibe. Like if you spend
time in my community, it's pretty obvious we don't hate. Like
sometimes the son will call me or my community anti-semitic cuz
there are some anti-semitic jokes that I I make. I think there's
a lot of I think there's a lot of funny jokes that can be racist
or >> I happen to not think the community is racist. Not
>> ever. Well, it's pretty obvious that my community is
not like an anti-semitic community. Whereas a son will never
make those kinds of jokes per se, but his community buys into
a lot of the like um like Zionist occupied government. And you
see even like the young Turks and everything now are going hardcore.
I think that kind of anti-semitism is a lot more insidious and
damaging than
>> that the argument is public opinion swaying away from
Zionism,
representative opinion not moving in the same direction. That's
that's like the argument.
Why is why is representative positions not changing? Why are
they not changing with public opinion? Right?
That's that's like the entire argument. So you could you could
get mad about like the Zog comments and stuff, but people are
using incendiary rhetoric to drive home a point.
So I don't know. I find it useful to engage with the point and
say maybe don't use dog whistles, >> you know, >> although
it's not really a dog whistle. Zog's not really dog whistle.
>> Telling jokes even if those people are like a little
bit hateful. >> What Destiny doesn't want to admit or maybe
just doesn't realize is that after years of constant controversy,
he's conditioned his community to carry out his bidding and defend
his actions no matter how reprehensible the crime. I should just
make like a guideline for all this, right? Always deny the initial
thing. Say there's no context or just don't address it at all.
Say the other side is lying. Make up some allegation. Get everybody
in your orbit to carry the message. All of your sickopantic fans
>> Oh, he's just doing another thing where he explains
exactly how he works, right? >> Carry the exact same message.
And then if there's anybody ostensibly that's on your side. Um,
>> by the way, this is why you guys wonder why he like
goes to food shops, why he platforms like certain people. He
just needs other people who can make allegations, who can review
content of people talking [__] about him and give
his message without it being him alone. Because when it's him
standing alone, he looks horrible. But when he has other people
doing it, other people helping him, it looks way better, right?
Even if those people are,
it doesn't matter that there's somebody out there who's helping
him and he can give audience to anybody who's willing to help
him,
right? So they can they can totally lie. They can be totally
like they can be totally um mentally deficient. They can lie.
They can not understand. They can misrepresent the other people
like his enemies. And that doesn't matter because he's not the
one doing it, right? It's the Ben Shapiro play. He doesn't want
to have to deal with the criticisms, the actual criticisms of
him. He doesn't want to deal with them at all. Right? He wants
to lie and not be not be questioned, not be criticized. So, he
needs his Matt Walsh. All right? That's like uh you know, counterpoints
in this case. And he needs his like Andrew Claven, that's like
food shops, okay?
He needs those people who can take the positions that that he
can't he doesn't want to take. He doesn't want to be held to.
He needs those people, right?
It's just
ah it's gross. He's explaining it. He's explaining is very direct
is very intentional. Or just don't address it at all. Say the
other side is lying. Make up some allegation. Get everybody in
your orbit to carry the message. All of your sickopantic fans
will carry the exact same message. And then if there's anybody
ostensibly that's on your side um or there's anybody that uh
is even on your side then you just harass the out of them until
they acquies until they give into it to all the harassment and
they have to change their opinion. At a certain point, it comes
down to people wielding their audience as a weapon or as a shield
from controversy or from, you know, attacks by other creators
because it's something that's so common and it's something that
even I contribute to as someone who's made a fair amount of videos
that like cover
>> Um, I mean, what I mean, what what about it? I mean,
people It's just the nature of crowds anywhere, right? Countries
do >> Try to do this to Pisco. I mean, I'm sure it happens
to basically everybody,
Yeah. I mean, the with Pisco was about as bad as it gets, right?
Like, I'm not going to say I'm as squeaky clean as Pisco is most
of the time, but he kind of just made up like the the gripes
against Pisco. Like, Pisco did essentially nothing wrong. And
Destiny manufactured a way to criticize that didn't even make
sense. if you could slow down at all and just evaluate the statements
he was making. But every time Pisco tried to do that, counterpoints
would pull his out and start off in the middle of the train like
he is a homeless person who has no purpose in any argument except
to obiscate, right? Like Destiny steals a purse from Pisco and
then Pisco goes to chase him and Counterpoints gets up in the
middle of the train between the two of them, between Destiny
running away and Pisco and just starts whipping his dick out.
That's like Counterpoint's whole purpose in life. Uh activist
groups do it. >> Oh, he also Yes. frame the dude it's so
crazy how he's just like creatively written that apparently his
anti-fan communities dox people
right or sorry that I mean I assume when people say anti-fan
communities he means me and queen that's how he's referred to
us right but they don't even say me and anymore cuz then we asked
for proof so now they just say anti-fan communities right
and and kiwi farms it's like bro I wasn't involved you gave all
the information to doc rose to kiwi farms directly via the DG
chat. It's literally in the logs. You literally bragged about
doing it to Ellie. You said why? If you don't know, but I gave
the all the information they needed to find her. I helped them
find her and I I can have that. That is a piece of that is a
piece of evidence that's sitting out on the internet and nobody
can engage with it. Nobody can engage with the fact that I had
nothing to do with that being provided. I didn't help with Rose
getting docs. I didn't do there, but I will still get blamed
for it. I'll get a portion of the blame for it for no reason.
for no discernable reason. Nobody can defend any reason I should
be held liable for Rose getting docked somehow.
And he just he just openly lies. He openly makes things up trying
to get other people to believe it. And the sad thing is is I
thought there were like principal people around. I thought this
was like one person who was like just a weird psychopath. And
then I thought the other people were principled, but I get lied
about and nobody cares to go correct that. I work so hard to
correct like the lies about Pisco, lies about Loaderbox, these
people. But it'll never get returned and it's a little black
pilling. You have to hope it all fails in the end. Like people
do end up, you know, not that Pisco and Lurbox should fail if
they don't stand up for me. Like they can do whatever they want.
I just like I kind of thought I kind of thought people would
stand on business. Like Counterpoint seemed like a guy who's
going to stand up business with morals. He didn't do that at
all. He just totally threw his morals in the trash. I I was extremely
naive in this way.
But you know, I'm woken up now. We're fine. We're going to make
it. >> Does it? They they're just taking notes from him,
right? Like the pe the audience will follow the the streamer
in terms of how they do it. I think the other day, what did he
was like? He called me like
so like four nicknames in a row. >> I was calling you Destitz.
You like Israel so much. You'd be more Alan Destitz than uh Destiny.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Destiny's main tactic has been to focus everybody's
negative attention onto Hassan [__] and away from
his own repeated bad behaviors.
And Oh, this is good analysis, right? This is what Destiny does.
Destiny never answers for any of his behavior. He never gets
like he's never willing to answer for it at all. He doesn't explain
why he did it. He doesn't he doesn't like acknowledge it and
he'll lie about it later. At best from Destiny, you'll get like
a momentary like, "Oh, I kind of did something bad." But he will
just lie about it later. This is what happened with the Pixie
stuff, right? When he came out and said, "Oh yeah, it's like
guys, don't go after Pixie. That would be crazy. Just be, you
know, let victims be victims. It's all fine. Don't don't talk
about how, you know, you don't need consent. don't do any crazy
arguments like that defending me. And then later he's just lied
about it. He didn't believe any of that, right? He was just hoping
he'd get through it. >> And it's actually working. >> When
Assan goes out and he does podcasts, he he just gets very little
uh I guess like traction outside of Twitch. But but when I go,
my my poll will be five times greater sometimes. And I think
that kind of bothers him. And I think he realized that. So he's
kind of been more intentional about trying to reach out at least
for mainstream media pieces. Although I don't think he's going
to find the success he's looking for there either. he does get
institutional support. Hassan does have interactions with these
people. Uh and that's because um currently they don't look far
enough and >> big cope. Um there's a thing that happens
with Destiny's audience. I talked about this with Gropers, but
it happens with Destiny's audience, too. Every single algorithm,
if you have like a cult-like following of people who are decentralized,
not in the same place, every algorithm will be fooled by that.
You have people who are the second your content drops, they're
going to go to it, they're going to upload it, they're going
to watch the whole thing. YouTube will skyrocket that content
automatic every time. And I don't think Hassan has dedicated
followers in that same way or the same volume that Fuentes or
Destiny do. So you can confound every algorithm on Earth. You
can just like totally skyrocket up if you have people who are
willing to upvote your stuff to tune into it immediately. Upvote
it and go hard supporting you to seeing how much of a enemy of
the Democrats Hassan [__] is. Um and I hope that
that can change in the future. The goal is to maximize, for instance,
um, attention and and eyes on him and impressions as much as
possible. It's all about just eyes on it's all about attention
and impressions. Since the beginning of 2025, when the revenge
allegations first dropped, there have been 10 major media articles
about Destiny's case. When Hassan's dog slipped on her canvas
bed and yelped, Destiny and Dan Saltman worked tirelessly to
spread the narrative that Hassan [__] was covertly
shocking his dog with an e-collar to keep it in place during
his live stream. >> I also like how the dog clipped its
foot on something, whatever that means. Um, but Hassan doesn't
care about it. He's not interested in it. He has no idea what
it was. This is apparently the first time this has ever happened,
right? Like I don't think has the dog ever yelped on stream before?
So like what? There's so many indications that he's lying. There's
so many He's like so obviously lying. It's so cringe. >> Dude,
this dog is is causing this guy so much problem. He's >> more
than anything else.
>> More than anything I've done, which is, you know, sad,
but also like, you know, it is what it is. I learned from them
because I I learned from them because they spent so much time
[__] over Ethan Klein
with saying his dog was fed cheese and I was just like, you know
that's a good strategy. Let's [__] do that [__]
>> That accusation led to over 20. >> Um, no. I mean,
this video is just like interesting. I don't think it's like
a like shot or something.
I think he just got some interviews here. I do think Hold on.
I do think Destiny talking about when you when you correlate
Dan talking about how the community harassment works when you
correlate like Destiny talking about what he I think he was talking
about how Hassan works but how he handles controversy.
I think there's like some good moments here. There's good bones
to this video. It's just like maybe it's not really proving anything
new.
I think uh
it might be good for his channel. It's probably not as good for
a lot of people who are aware of most of the information around
this stuff. Right. Let me look. I'll Oh, hold on. I'll check
out the the comments after. It's getting downvoted a lot as well.
Probably getting, you know, this is what I'm talking about. The
other thing about Desi's community is they will obsessively go
around to content that's negative of him and download it and
bgade it in the same way that gropers do, right? Like they will
they will negatively affect the stuff that is anti- Destiny and
positively affect the stuff that's pro Destiny in a way that
very few like you need you need absolute adherence. You need
total commitment, total cultlike commitment to get this to happen
to other people, like to go in and brigade this stuff like this.
And DJers have it. Gropers have it. I don't know of another community
that's like this. It It's always been these two communities to
me. >> 25 major media articles covering the Hassan [__]
dog collar drama. Destiny himself has made over 300 videos talking
about Hassan on his YouTube channel. And that's not even including
live streams. Give me the Hassan clip. I need my hater clips
ready. >> Hassan bad. >> But unironically, >> but
I'm worse. >> It's not fair to chastise all of America
for slavery because only 2% of Americans own slaves. Like Hassan
would have been part of this is I just want people to own that
they like Destiny. I That's all I want, right? People are like
such all over the internet. It's It's the Trump
The Trump comparisons abound. Do you guys remember how on like
Reddit and Reddit and Twitter people go like, "I'm not a fan
of Trump, but I'm not a fan of Trump, but I'm not like a Republican,
but it's the Tim P." People do that with like supporting Destiny
now. It's very weird to me. Um, you know, I think Destiny's like,
but did you think about how maybe he's just really getting everything's
overblown? I'm not I'm not like a fan of Destiny, but did you
think about how like maybe this is all fake? Um, like No, I didn't
think about that.
that 2%. Like that's the kind of person here. This is insane
to me. Jesus. >> Yeah, this is a classic one, too. Listen,
I was a fan of this guy, but you know what? Destiny, I was a
fan of Hassan, but you know, Destiny really made a good point
here. You check like the Reddit history. It's all in r/ Destiny.
All the comments are r/ Destiny. God, I hate this guy. If you're
a trans person and you take any like direction from Hassan, you're
actually such a loser. When I was living in LA, me and Hassan
actually played a game of horse and I destroyed him. And it was
actually from that moment onwards that our relationship started
to deteriorate. >> Fighting against Hassan [__]
and his community of radical socialists has become the main goal
not just of Destiny and Dan Saltman but tons of other creators
on the internet. >> There's a few people in there that
it's like this battle that's going on if you will. I guess you
could say asminold is in there. Techone is in there. >> There's
always like large communities that are kind of like controlling
the direction. Um my community is a large one. XQC's is decently
big. Asmin. >> Um, Zan Cali, I don't think so. So, hold
on. I believe communities get this way through mass purges rebuild/
distillation events. Were there events like this for the Gropers?
I have no idea. I I I know people don't believe me, but I swear
I like started following online politics, seeing like a Destiny
versus Vosch debate on I think Written House. That's where I
got into like Twitch politics. That's when I first joined like
Destiny's community and stuff. It was like some debate on written
house and I watched that and I was like, "Oh, this is kind of
interesting." And eventually after watching Destiny for a while,
I found out who Fuentes was. I watched some of his content, but
I always watch Destiny's more. So, I only know DG's events and
timeline. I don't really know anything about the Gropers, but
Nick has always been like an overtly I'm creating a cult of personality.
Like Nick has kind of overtly been building a cult the whole
time, right?
Like Nick object Nick jokes about how he's so much better than
everybody and like he is Destiny thinks he's like logically arguing.
He tries to like logically show that he is different. Okay, guys.
Like I'm so different from everybody. I can do polyamorous relationships.
Nick's always like, "Yeah, I'm just built I'm built different."
And and Dassi will try to convince you with evidence. Nick's
like, "I'm better than you. I'm I know I'm better than you. You
know you're I'm better than you. And if you think differently,
leave." It's like a It's like a different approach.
Nick Nick was building overtly like a cult of personality from
the beginning. Destiny tries to convince people he's not doing
that and then he purges anyone who disagrees. There's totally
different approaches. Golds is a large one and then Hassan's
is kind of there. Um the dynamic right now is Asthma Gold, Excy,
and my community all hate Hassan. Uh so if I say anything negative
in that direction, it'll get a lot of traction, but not necessarily
because they like me, just because they hate Hassan. Anytime
we see a Hassan [__] post, we try to post really
mean and rude stuff about him so he cries about on a stream.
Um, yeah, it's a hugely coordinated effort. I think I spend probably
over $200,000 a month on bots and to go and spam bad stuff about
Hassan [__] >> Okay, good. Okay, so me and
you do the same thing. Awesome. I do that on GE. >> Yeah,
I don't I don't have as much money as you. $200,000 a little
bit out of my price range. The concept of a large group of people
being against capitalism is rightfully scary to large creators
online who are held up by the >> Oh no, don't be cringe.
Don't be cringed. Come on, man. >> Capitalist system to
those creators fearmongering with red scare politics. >> Dude,
it's not they're not they're not thinking about like capitalism.
They're not that's not occurring to people here. It's not they're
not thinking like oh no as like one of the as one of the boogeoisi
I will be in very much trouble. That's not what they're doing.
That's not it's not a part of it. Ah >> and galvanizing
your base to go after the tankies probably seems like a very
good content strategy. But in actuality it's just another method
in the culture war playbook. >> Drama is interesting. I
mean the the history of the world is is drama. What's your favorite
hobby?
>> Yeah. Um, I have a standard poodle and I uh I like video
editing.
>> You have a standard poodle like a dog?
>> Okay. I don't know anything about poodles, so I can't
make any analogy there, but I've been streaming for 16 years
and fighting and arguing with people and confrontation is kind
of I guess part of what I do and it's kind of fun for me.
Building your online community up by going to war with other
creators and their communities is something that's incredibly
commonplace these days. There's a whole news politics and entertainment
system in place ready to be misused and exploited by guys like
Destiny to stop progressive ideas from actually breaking through.
But they
>> No, it's to maintain themselves as like thought leaders.
I don't think it's to stop progressive ideas from breaking through
at all. It's like this guy thinks these people have you know
some ideological dedication to a movement. No, the movement is
themselves.
Yeah. This is this is him thinking that this is all being done
under the like opices of making themselves thought leaders of
making themselves more rich and more famous. That's that's all
it is. This is uh there is no there is no coordinated thing to
being a capitalist. They're they're being they're being a capitalist
through their actions. they they are they are embodying capitalism,
right? But that it's not that they're like thinking, "Oh, capitalism
has to be defended because we're in an ideological struggle against
socialism or something like that." They're doing they're doing
it because capitalism in and of itself probably is something
like just being selfish and being greedy. Things are starting
to change. Many are starting to get fed up with politicians failure
to address the labor, healthcare, and cost of living crisis in
America. despite all of those raging issues. >> True, but
he does hate progressives. He hates Hassan. He hates people who
support Hassan. You're you're actually you are falling for the
idea that he has legitimate political views and it's not just
entirely spitebased. You're falling for the idea that Bosch could
be wrong on any read he makes of Destiny on a personal level.
And trust me, I fell for that view once, too. But Vos saw into
Destiny's soul. He pondered his orb and he said exactly what
Destiny does. It's just spitebased politics. Okay. all all of
his content is pure petty grievance. It's why he spends so much
time covering his own court case now, right? It's so much of
what he does as a content creator, what he does politically is
just pure petty, small-minded grievance, okay?
It's it's not some ideological thing. If you if you evaluate
him that way, you will not understand what he does and why he
does it. Like, it won't make any sense to you. >> Most
of the discourse is clouded by the culture war. In any case,
that's where we're at in our culture. That's where we're at in
the uh realm of commentary. And these guys are way too predisposed
with silliness as opposed to solving any of the crises that are
personally responsible for. And the worst part about it is that
for many Americans, they're fine with that. They like it. They're
like, "No, this is great. This is awesome." Yeah. No, keep me
invested in this silly gay way to end it. Yeah. I don't really
love it at the end. I just feel like the read is bad. That's
That's why I don't like it. I just feel like the read is bad
there at the end. That's too bad. It's a fun little video, but
I think the read at the end is
I It's just unfortunate. They want to They want it to be that.
And I get why you want it to be that. That's like your your enemy.
You can like kind of galvanize against them.
I think
I don't know. Do you guys think there's a problem with viewing
it that way? If in if in effect it turns into that anyway, are
they are they is he even wrong for thinking that like in effect
all of those people will be against Hassan? And it's possible
that in effect it will all be,
you know, for nothing or whatever if if Hassan's destroyed or
if those communities are destroyed. Like there might be some
argument there. Ripping, you could always hop in the Discord
and come and argue about why you don't like the content or something.
Perfectly welcome. You won't do that. You're a total.
But that's fine.
People come in and they're like, "You you stop following the
court case." No, I didn't. I literally covered it yesterday.
The only thing I didn't cover was a transcript for stuff I'd
already read all of the briefs and the outcome on. That's the
only thing I didn't cover. And it's because a bunch of fslur
diggers kept coming in and going, "Cover the transcript. Cover
the transcript. Cover the transcript." No, you guys
You I don't care.
I covered the outcome. like of the motion from which that transcript
arose.
Get it? A rose.
What is this? >> Came to be. None of >> these people
know whatest means. Pest is just like the new standin for
um whatever. It doesn't mean anything like it doesn't mean it
doesn't mean just it's just like a random thing that you just
like whatever.
>> No, you are like a you are like somebody who's a
a past. You you are you overtly everything. You're like a weird
just a weirdo freak in DMs with tons of women. You are an actual
pest. You're just Darius. You keep it private instead of public.
That's that's all that's all it is. Like I don't What are we
doing here?
It definitely means something. It's definitely not like a weird
thing to use. It definitely applies to Destiny is different.
No. No is different. Sorry. I I think it has to do with somehow
him trying to paint himself as like Blue Pill before, right?
It's like that like he painted himself as somebody who would
have like respectful conversations with women and then women
would DM him and he would immediately make every conversation
in a super in a super offputting way for like all of them all
the time. Like that's that's more what I'm talking about in terms
of fest. And obviously like the the crimes, the secret recording,
the the non-consentual sharing, all of this stuff, right? Need
to show the logs. I think a lot of people have po posted logs,
but any logs I had or have, I mean, I'm probably not posting
them publicly. They were never shared with me to be posted publicly.
I have no interest in doing that. The year the [__]
year of him finger wagging his chat for comments about women
kill me. Well, and then he's just like all all these gold digging
he's on his like gold digging [__]
arc with with regards to Pixie. It's very funny.
It's totally making [__] up about her. He's basically
techone at this point.
It's very funny.